bro ignore that my sleep right now literally hold on hold on a minute hold
on a minute hold up wake up okay I'm awake I'm awake I promise I'm awake
okay we calibrated I'm sorry wait where's popcorn hold on I'm at
I woke up early to record ASMR so my Yumi collab is I've got all the raw
stuff I need for it now I'm sorry I'm just getting comfy I've been awake for a
very long time so I'm very coherent right now for the for the first time in
forever I have a brain and I can actually communicate good morning
good morning good morning where's hold on let me pop popcorn we film because
popcorn we films really cute I hope you're ready to turn me into a wee pop
you can see you can sit in my chest like imagine you're sitting inside the
yukata like that's how you sit like there oh no you're swinging I tried I
got sleep yeah so I woke up at 2 a.m. it took me an hour to become coherent
because I was like oh what is this time why am I awake and I was like piss
arson about obviously as always I see has a new role play up if you haven't
seen it and she's a puppy girl and she's so fucking cute can't handle she's so
fucking cool I disney in it she bees and has an ASMR role play that's gonna go
up after I finish streaming and I told her that and she said that's fine she's
no bother so that's the good news because she's no bother and so after
sheepster stream today once I finish sheepsters should have an ASMR role play
coming up she's also asked for more scripts so don't be surprised if you see
a script right and scream stream coming up and we're just ready for she be only
exclusively for the entire stream and she yelled when I had max volume
don't listen to me I'm max volume what are you doing to you're just you're
punished you're shitting yourself go go to the bathroom but yes I'm awake I'm
coherent I'm a minute minute minute minute minute minute minute minute minute minute
minute and I asked also a question I'm a question she be to record wooden soup
ASMR for me so I could finish another collab off because I attempted wooden
soup one time ASMR and it was awful right has everyone got their legal
streaming service ready for episode one of Vivi Florentide in the water it's in
our toothpaste it's in the pipes is everyone ready for that I'm gonna move
over a little bit you can't watch cuz you're at work what you just got you
should watch she be stream then she be such the stream and something you I
think you need the context of the anime to progress like to proceed remember
to smash that bell subscribe and ring that like button I tried I'm sorry Vivi
vermentide I tried like it's fluoride or something legal and paid for service
well yes of course and I mean you can watch even if you can't see that you're
puking on yourself go to the bathroom oh that would actually be your pain
yourself go in the bathroom reflow the fuck is everywhere it's in the carpet
all the carpet oh can I tell you a disgusting story about my family so
in my grandparents house there was a cutout circle in front of one of the
seats and we just assumed like that it meant and like my granddad had been
sitting and getting up off the seat and it wore the carpet down over time the
secret was my granddad went out on a bender slouched over the chair puked
and it was so embedded in the carpet that they cut out the hole in the carpet
that was the big mystery secret to why the carpet was so worn down at his seat
it was like the revelation in the cuttles family when that came out all of
us were in an absolute uproar we're like what do you mean you went out on a
bender what like we were like asking for details or locations why the popcrawls
you did name them because we didn't think granddad went now and literally fuck
themselves up we're like we're like give us the details we all just assumed it
was cuz he sat in the seat so much like out getting up in the friction kit like
because of it how did the inspection go you want to know what a bloody fucking
was oh so I didn't even have to go offline you know what it was it was
the fencing the last tenant put up that look like I put up fencing on the
weekend that look like I can what DIY even stands for no it was the fencing
that they put up I could fucking shag him I didn't have to go off stream last
yesterday absolutely shag him because I was I literally said I was like as much
as I'm like a good neat max if someone's coming to fucking inspect the you know
inspect my weirs I get all nice and clean I polish those knobs you know what
I'm saying mmm mmm and oh my god Spidey thank you for the 50 bomb yesterday I
missed it or you did it when I was offline
no you didn't when I was offline 14 hours ago thank you Spidey for the 50
bomb and god the 21st was pretty well I got hammered I broke my foot and didn't
go the other feet not the feet there's somebody little intricate bones of the
feet they took away mommy time for that literally because I was like I'm not
being funny as much as a neat back fucking place was spotless fucking
exactly unless you want to unless they wanted to be like mmm sorry your piece
of cat nibble was outside the ball on the floor oh fucking shoot me then no
it was the fence and outside that had nothing to do with me I was like no
your last tenants fucking had that that's not to do with me because I'll
actually said to them the reason I'm renting this place is because I have
fucking kitty cats and that cute oh no I'm gonna puke I'm gonna puke if I
think about it too much anyway so the good news is Yumi collab has been
recorded so that might actually be my next record next collab that comes out
because it's very simple to edit versus the Poseidon collab which should
technically be the next one that comes out but I don't think it's gonna open
which means they didn't do a proper inspection when the previous tenants
left her yeah and they like claimed that they cleaned they got a professional
cleaner in the house and everything and I was like did you fuck did you fuck so I
argued against that but the thing is the landlord is nice to me like he's a
Chinese man and he does think he a fuck what I do I was like oh can I do this can
I do that and like I've got a recording that fucking takes up like so much space
I was like I'm gonna put this up and all that and he's like yeah okay like he
has to text me because he can't speak English so he like takes everything and
his wife takes me as well she's adorable she's like hi hope you're well and I'm
like yeah did you finish the mavescript yet no I've not sent that off I'll try and
fit wrap it up I've got a few things to wrap up and do not be surprised if next
week is filled with nothing but writing streams I'm needing to get a and I'm
needing to get there's so many kind v-tubers who have agreed to collab with
me and my dumb ass has been leaving them on had read and stuff like that which
isn't very polite so don't be surprised if next week's membership streams are
collaborate right right right and I'm looking at you guys to finish the
roleplays for me I'll see I'll get it started I'll get that engine revving room
room you know I'm saying but you guys have to use your head for the rest of it
thank you why did I sound like a discord predator yeah baby girl yeah
reflin I'm gonna go bring you so how you're so mature for your age I'm sorry
right okay wait what is this the right episode episode one season one the
better be only one season to make everyone happy with my singing if I got
the right anime as everyone read raise everyone ready the way I do it is three
two one go and then on go we go okay so if it's smoking are you ready everyone
ready it's too pretz away when Eva three two one go oh yeah baby score oh she's
well that's loud in my headset sorry let me just turn to my head set a little bit
gorgeous it's to make everyone happy oh wait what this is an idol anime
oh my god oh oh shit oh hi yo good morning oh oh fuck say fuck 4 a.m. let's
fucking get a boogie on what's going on here oh I like this oh my god it's me
oh
I
Hey
Are the androids
What
What the fuck did you recommend me to watch?
Are the Android idols
I
What the fuck are we watching
What I'm
Okay, I'ma let them anime
No, leave me alone. Go away Android
No, go away Android hate
He's like really injured so I'm gonna slurp my tea
I
What
And I don't even know what to say what the what do you want me to commentate I am as confused as you are
I
Episode one my code to bring happiness. There's not one that has to make who is this
Mommy what happened
Hydration
I
Know you can't see my real life face. I know each of her but
What is my purpose to sing oh my god
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna be like oh, this is Marcy's dream Marcy likes to sing
I
Where's mommy's purpose to ink the reflins. Oh, yeah
Does everyone have something on the top left that says like project singularly execution please on time, right?
That's not just me, right?
Okay, it's part of the anime gotta go to go to go to get
You
Know mommy you've been hacked
Oh
Wait that hurt internal
You
What you got a little scamper you
That's so cute
Oh
And now we wake up
Tan Joe be oh my dear to the beach
So into the nuke's drop
Oh
Actually the rebraved on an AI with blue hair because I'm surprised didn't call
Hatsune Miku thank you Nate for becoming a member. I hope you enjoy the emotes. I
Should be having the emotes for the girls in four days. I'm waiting for an update. I
Want that filled batch
Then as ears and she bees and manual all be sent off. I actually know other she be Nazura's together
Hold on a minute
From time before in the past she sees what happened
Have to have occurred for her be able to see yeah
No
Yeah
You open the box
It's given Wheatley from portal to
You
We're destroying the high table of AI's
Oh, I think that me. I think me and this anime gonna get along real well. Hold on a minute
Hold on a minute. We destroy in the high table of AI
Oh
They have like little houses
I thought it would be like future Rama where they get like a cube that they walk in seed and that's it
You
Oh
Oh, he embodies the pair. Oh, that's fucking creepy though
Okay
Oh
This quick when you walk away
She's not happy
Wow
Go
Becoming for rent of your ink and you're like, no mommy refactory period. I don't give a fuck. Give me that ink
But no one came he predicted it
No, no don't be like that
Who is this refactory person you keep talking about I'll fight him off as you keep joining you
But mummy I just think 10 times a day
I recharge after yesterday's pic. I'm still raging after that
My mission has always been to make everyone happy while I'm singing please
You
He gets run over
Does she save them
She does what bad ass
What a badass. Oh, I'm hooked. Sorry I'm hooked
Her being in an idol outfit as well just like adds to the badass. Sorry. Oh, let's do it. Let's do it
Oh
Fine incredible
Over making allies
Hello
You
I did not like that way of communication. Hey little mama, let me whisper in your ear
My autistic AI robot idol I do like that
I
It's kind of creepy
Me at the idol meeting meeting great. I'm just staring in your soul telepathically. I'm gonna fuck you up
You
The tolling bow
I
Don't know if she can read my mind
Holy shit
You
Don't know we changed the future. Oh
Oh
Demetre I was doubly done
It's silent, right did my audio just die
I think did my audio die on my death
Dema hello, that's it. Is that me? No, it's silent. Okay
Okay, I was like damn
Fucking that gunshot made me lose my hair and I'm gonna have ringing in my ears in a minute. Holy shite
Holy shite. Okay. Um
All right, that's all good to go and Gucci Gucci
and
I
Right, okay, right. Um, right. Is there post credits? Ah fucking hate post credits
Fucking can we skip post?
Oh
I heard
some
I don't hear any music
Oh for fuck's sake are my files corrupt. I mean is my streaming service corrupt
Hold on
Uh
Can you guys hear something right now? I don't see a post credit scene wait, why don't I see
Minus 5612
You hear me. Yes all companies are corrupt. Yeah
There isn't one that's the next one my version has no post credit
All right, fuck it. We'll skip to the next one and pray that the audio works
Right, are we ready for episode two?
All right, let me just change it in my wee thing
My apart right this episode says it's 22 minutes 45. Who is that? Stop burping in the night. Why is he?
He may manage
Run episode two
Okay
Are we ready?
For episode two
And I say it on go. Okay
three two
One go. Okay. I can hear again. What the fuck?
A quarter note a quarter note
Okay
Oh
We need to be incognito
Oh, fuck
Holy fuck, are we gonna make it out? I feel like this guy's toast
You
Cockatanny, uh, excuse me hit your names. What you want to repeat that last one for it cockatanny
Damn, you've been out in the sun too long your cock got a tan. Hey, uh, uh, come on. Come on
No
Wait, isn't this just overwatched where it's in yacht? Oh, no, it's nothing. Yeah, uh, man, uh, man. Yeah, I'm sorry
Okay
Yeah, I haters sleep
You
Wait, so he can't see her or my being dumb
Gossip
Ah, these are bombas
Um what
Uh-huh
Oh fuck we're too late
Oh, are we too late? I really want him to survive. I want to win. I want her to win so badly
Oh fuck
Oh
I'm gonna say
Cheeky wishy
Oh
No
Oh my god does he still die?
The dubstep gun stop that's funny
Oh
One more time
Okay good
Oh
Wait what
I got pranked
I failed for it
Oh my gosh
Oh
I think we're gonna have to install that fucking weaponized A.I. update
Oh yeah piss
I think we're going to the past the point where we've kept you alive for long enough now you fucking relax alright then he'd be starting accusing us of trying to kill you
We're fucking trying our best here you just calm down son you just let us do what we need to do
Like we might be bickering back and forth but he has a chance
No not the tear drop I can't take any more tear drops
Oh no it's her blood sort
Wait why did she see that
There we go they're going to
Huh
That's not very reflective
Yeah
She slumbered
Oh
She's squirting
Sorry I shouldn't have said that
It's a very emotional scene
Damn she's fucking rich
Damn
The one that was trying to keep you alive yes please stand up let's go
We're analizing running diagnostics
We all need to escape fast
Uh
By blown up to fuck
I love this sorry this is the funniest thing I've ever seen
She'll wrap the building up in tin foil pop it in the microwave and blow up to fuck
This is such a good anime
Why didn't you not make the human go first
There's
That looks really badass and that wee bun design I like it
You're not going to like hold on to him or something
Now we're not just going to like
Yeah okay that's what I thought was going to happen
Okay she saved him
Oh yeah that's a good shot
That was cool
He mad that he in love with her he pissed that AI is nice
He mad he looked down everything I knew was wrong
I can't believe it
He's experiencing cognitive dissonance
See
Fucking hell getting a bit philosophical out here
Beep beep
No
That's like it looks like the link thing when he talks about the future like when it goes upwards
Do you think they're compensating for something
P.O.V what the average girl thinks the guy is like one inch shorter than her
Let's talk about rage bait that was a meme about rage bait by the way
That was a meme about rage bait by the way
Oh she just wants to save him
No
You're fucking trolling
Oh no I'm crying what the fuck
Are you serious who fucking wrote that
Oh my god what the fuck
No did he start playing the fucking credit music roll the clip back undo it the fuck
Oh my god that was the ween that gave her the teddy now she has the fucking stare at the teddy that the fucking ween gave her all the time
What the fuck you guys told me about that
Oh my god so she can't have pals then again oh jeez you're an 100 year waller and you can't have pals oh by the way
I'm the fucking embodiment of the teddy bear the dead girl that you never rescued
What the fuck it's supposed to be about singing
Bruh they came out of nowhere
I feel like I need to be sick
Not to be dramatic or anything but I feel sick
Oh my god what the fuck
Right let's go episode 3
No did he be playing that fucking funeral piano music in your end credit you fucking bastard
What the hell
Right are we ready for episode 3
I'll change the music title
Yeah what the fuck
Thank you man nowhere
I'm not crying baby but I'm gonna do that
Right are we ready
Right ok
On go we'll start the next episode ok
3 2 1 go
I actually feel sick to my stomach
I can't even handle that that's just fucked up
Oh
Now we're getting a new enemy introduced
A naughty AI
She needs a spankin
Oh no
New tabling
Is this like the first actual intro we get now
You
I just burped cause I'm ready to throw up now after that
I'll calm down don't worry
You
That one's quite a shock
Illuminate yeah the new fucking future pun
Oh she's getting idle presents
You
He had a bath
Wait 15 years
Am I on the right episode
You
She be red
Hello harem
Did you enjoy shebe's pop-up stream
We're watching fliratide
I'm becoming a weeb and I'm proving it by watching anime with you
If you'd like to join in I have a timestamp and the episode number three
Was she naked
And then hold on sorry I saw another nakedness in the corner of my eye
Hello harem
I hope you're doing well
She almost cried again
Enjoy the Elton then
If you have anime streaming service there's a timestamp you can join in at any time
I've never seen it before so no spoilers is all I ask but I'll redirect into Emmer's
afterwards
Shebe leaked that she has a song coming
I'ma leak something about Shebe back
Are you ready for it
Shebe agreed to do the interviews with me
Get leaked on
Emmer's is a member stream today
I don't think it's there's back yet is she
Is it Friday in America
Is it Friday in America right now
It's Wednesday
Oh
Merci Reed
I need to go I can't watch the rest of this
I'm sorry
I'll timestamp all the episodes by the way when the VOD is finished
I was your timestamp in the future
It's Thursday for me
Oh
Are you squiddin' me right now
I just entered and mumma is already crying
I won't be able to watch this stream because of work but I'll be there for the 2am one
Have fun mumma and reeflings
Thank you mumma lo
Sorry that you can't do that
I cried once okay I'm sure I'll be fine for the rest
Space Hotel
Would you
I was gonna say would you go into space without me who's scared to leave my house
I'd have to be very doped up for space
Are we about to do a space mission
I
I would not want to bet my life on space hotel real
Would you get mush and sickness in space
I'm not sure
I
Love her hair like that. Oh my god. Sorry, but here confirm for Jim to I love the little bot like button in the back bit
bits coming out
Oh
She's a noisemus
I
Don't trust her
I don't trust her after that scene at the star. I think it's like long fucking blue a blonde hair
I
Soon as I soon as a management go one big family
You know getting free overtime for me boss makes a dollar I'll make a day. That's why I shit on company time
Hmm
What's wrong with blonde hair the opening
See that the opening scene I told you I told you
Hmm defective
I
Oh, I should have been in a wee school, I don't know.
Okay, I love these mission debriefs.
I like that it's in a musical setting. These debriefs as well. Oh no, it's a brief, not debrief sort.
Where's the stealer? Taking the piss?
Yeah, it says pee at the end, like a pee pee.
This is cute.
She looks like another anime character.
Revolker credentials? You've been denied.
The inspection went fine, it was a misunderstanding, so I didn't even have to go offline. They were literally here for two things and then went away again and I'm like, yeah.
What?
Oh ya piss. Oh ya piss, she's gone rogue. She killed the master. Get Kludon, Lieutenant Colombo, where is it? And just one more thing.
Actually, we should watch Lieutenant Colombo. Just for the hell of it. Just a few random episodes. And just one more thing.
My mum loved watching Lieutenant Colombo.
Are you still being mum? Why is his eye funny?
Oh, he's joining. He's got a glass eye. Oh, I didn't know you could do that.
Hey, you're not supposed to be oof.
Oh, he's getting pampered.
It's been about seven years already.
He's got a glass eye.
Let's see, fuck off.
Maybe if I can't have it, no one can.
They played with pocket knives?
My idea of fun is, you know, beating up a game.
Ouchie.
Maybe she wasn't the bad guy all along.
We got infiltrated. She's not the baddie.
She destroyed something on the ship and had to sacrifice everyone and her way.
I don't think she's the baddie.
I think it'll be an infiltration mission for some information in the ship or intel.
I could be wrong. I think she's not the baddie.
I don't think she killed them.
I'm gonna pull it thickens.
Oh, no.
There's the pink beard.
Who will get justice? I'll spoke over it.
No, no, I'm confused. Is she the baddie or no?
No, I don't want fucking spoilers for the next thing. Stop with the fucking spoiler anime. You need to fucking wrap it up with the body spoilers for the next episode in the last episode. That needs to be wrapped up.
Stop fucking spoiling scenes. Am I mental? I just spoiled what's happening in the next year.
Fuck off.
The plot thickens just like my ass because I'm not doing any exercise.
Right, are we ready to go again? I'm hooked.
After this one, I'm gonna get some food and drink and hydrae and I'll take two of our breaks.
Are you ready?
Can anyone summarise what happened so far?
Teddy bear from future help blue hair girl save future.
What a fucking summary.
I'll count down and then on go we hit it.
Episode four. Three, two, one, go.
I'm gonna have to leave. Have fun. Thank you for hanging me Flynn.
Please don't worry if you can't hang for the full time. This is a long watch along.
I'm sorry.
Wait, he's older.
Wait, that's- is that us?
No.
She's the body!
Fuck it!
She's taking fucking the dead thing from the guy!
Fuck!
I keep getting switched and baited and baited and switched.
Fucking unbaited.
Fuck.
Fuck, you can un-bait yourself right now.
I can't follow.
I'm not smart enough to see through the plot.
You know how people are like,
Oh!
I can see the plot ten miles away.
I'm like,
Uh,
The plot is as thick as ink. The plot explains itself. The anime has me completely spun vested.
Will Donate some brain cells? No, I need just to be able to hook into the same brain cells as me.
The other anime is built different. Most of them are predictable.
Is this just like the most bizarre one?
Perfect low IQ, beloved.
Honestly.
Switch-sterbated.
I don't think I've seen a scene in it so far that I'd want to get commissioned of us together as...
Obviously the blackmail scene in the other anime.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's the sister?
Oh no.
Uh...
So the band kept her from going rogue.
Oh yeah, Pestas Titanium Steel!
Uh...
She was pranked!
But the worst kind of prank!
The imposter prank.
He's going to recognize us though.
Oh no.
Identity theft is not a joke!
Oh yes.
Oh no.
Bruh.
I'm not crying, okay?
No! Don't give us the fucking flashbacks! Come on!
Oh no.
Oh my god, it's the teddy bear her sister gave.
Bruh.
I'm not crying, I just have tears in my eyes.
But they're not dropping so it doesn't count.
Okay.
It's time.
No.
Room service about to bust the mess.
Why did her fucking lips change? Why is she gone?
Why does she randomly have a glow up?
She got a bit of like fucking blush on her cheek,
a bit highlighter, a bit of contour, what was that?
I love when anime randomly does stuff like that.
Okay, we're not looking at any post credit scenes by the way
because this literally got spoiled in the last one.
The buff went crazy.
Is she okay?
Do you know the muffin man?
Sorry.
It's just the way she said it.
Surprise!
Let's see.
Hmm.
Oh.
What the fuck they did? Oh.
Okay.
Sorry, that's not nice.
I don't mean that in an S3.
It's just because all the voices in this anime are high pitched
all the way up here and then this is the first voice that we have down here.
The bird tried to escape and it perished.
They literally went on a suicide mission.
Oh.
He remembers.
He got them cowboy beat-bop eyes.
She has her own agendination?
She wants to just keep them alive?
I don't know.
Oh.
Holy shit, the budget went into this.
What the fuck?
Can she fate? She can he fate it.
He's like 100 years in the future with EI.
She only wanted to serve?
Holy shit.
No, no, no, no, no.
Not the bracelet.
Teddy bear, can you like fucking throw that?
Does she implant a virus?
Oh, oh god, the symbolism is actually quite the fucking contrast.
Goddamn.
I feel like I just went insane.
I'm getting a sense for it ourselves.
Hello story repeats itself.
She does crash, but she crashes the scene.
At least the passengers are safe, holy fuck.
No!
The hair was intertwined in her bracelet.
She forgot the virus erased.
Can we watch anime that don't make me cry every 2 seconds? What the fuck?
Do you faint? Can we pick ones that are like funny ha ha? I can't even be watching this stuff.
Do you faint? Can we watch Sun Funny? I'm snot coming out my nose.
You picked this? Did I look like a fuck?
No way! I'm trying to be nice.
Oh no! The fucking last song! Oh my heart can't take this!
No more baby crying enemies please! Give me action next time!
Oh my god. Why are they pranking us like this?
No the last fucking words.
No! Am I gonna be greeting at the end of every episode?
Oh it's not!
Until the next mission I guess.
We need to fucking watch anime that don't make me cry.
Oh come on! I'm fucking sick! That was like the fucking stupid thing!
I'm fucking serious! I'm gonna be sick watching this anime!
I'm okay though. I promise I'm okay. I just don't want to be sad.
We're ready for episode 5. I'm ready to keep going. I'm gonna get a coma.
Is it good anime? I don't know what the problem is. It's really good anime. I read it very highly.
Are you ready for episode 5 everyone? Cause I'm ready for episode 5!
Oh my god! They did not have to do that fucking birth scene!
Right I'm gonna go get a can of cola. I'm gonna go for a pee as well.
Everyone go get a pee and a can of cola.
I'm not picking a sad fucking make me a weave next month. That's all I'm saying.
We need to pick happy anime cause I can't take this fucking emotional damage.
Go for a pee and get some drink. I'm gonna take a minute to pee as well. I'll be back in a moment.
I'm gonna get a can of cola.
Alright who's ready to get their ass beat by Salami?
Okay next time we're just watching Hentai. I can't take this emotional damage.
I got a cola bottle of water and a cheese string to make myself feel better.
I'm sure there's... I wanna rewatch that purple succulence one.
I actually got purple here.
Cheese string? Yeah the cheese is gonna make me feel better.
I'm gonna drink some water though.
Yeah you're in the trenches with me right now. Bro who's fucking picked this anime?
Okay we're ready for episode 5.
Surely I will not be crying any further after that raw copy.
Surely I will not drop any tears for the rest of this anime.
Are you ready? On go.
Three, two, one, go.
Yes a beautiful church. Which does admire the architecture. Surely I'm not gonna cry any further.
I'm opening up my cheese string. Oh my god it's us.
I can't rip it open. You give me these claws.
Oh AI and man are getting married in secret.
Curious. Curious.
As I said we're gonna skip the credits because they're leaking stuff and I don't want leaks.
I'm the only one that's allowed to leak.
So we've deviated the course of history. We've started a new branch.
Okay.
The Love Island is an AI metropolis.
Analysing.
Please do not be about the sky. I'm trying to eat and I'll vomit.
My pleasure.
Okay I'll be strong.
We're happy again. I promise we're happy.
Oh this will definitely not go bad. No.
Seven years. I'm not sure how many years. He tells us. He's like oh it's been 10 years. It's been 15 years.
So the we teddy bear will tell us. Okay I feel better now that I'm eating cheese.
I'm secretly a mouse right now.
Okay.
Was that gorgeous that shot?
Oh countdown.
May as well give strongy clanned or angel beats? What does this mean? Sorry.
I'm joking don't. No wait what does that mean? What what did you say? Wait what?
Mommy no wait what does that mean? Clanned?
Oh it's sad animes. Oh you want me to cry more? I'm not crying enough for you.
Find a way to sneak in.
I like how our room is changing.
Hi.
Oh he doesn't have to haze.
Oh.
Why is unexpected?
This is 2.0 debut. Oh my god congrats. I forgot to buy fanart for the debut.
2.0
Real.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Now don't give me flashbacks. I'll start greeting again. Don't think I won't stop crying.
No more sad violins. No more sad pianos. All happy.
Don't make me cry while I'm eating my cheese string. I've almost finished it.
I peel it apart.
Into little tiny strings. It's like a cylinder of cheese I'm eating right now.
And you've got to strip it apart.
Into little tiny strings.
We'll be analising.
And heels too.
Wee woo.
I'm just kidding.
Oh no, there's cum!
Slip caution, slippery when wet.
Wheel.
I've finished my cheese string.
I'm sorry. Not our ink reserves.
My batch of ink.
Do you feel better now?
Yeah.
I have my snack here, I have my cola.
I need to burp.
Oh, that was sick. That was sick. Sorry.
I'm sorry. Love you. I'm sorry.
That was my stomach content so I was regurgitating.
Sorry.
I forgot I'm not allowed to burp if I'm upset because I puke when I get upset.
I don't know if you get that, if I get too upset I'll throw up.
Metal flute.
Fuck.
Boi up, T-Fuck!
Sorry, that was my chair. Have you heard that?
No.
Like roof on the lake, was she?
Ow.
T-Fuck.
Microwave.
Er, yeah.
Put a bit tin foil around it.
We bet metal.
Into the microwave.
I don't know.
He's been 5 years, but T-8 knows you're going to pass.
Hello.
Hi, Greg.
Oh, Nanoboss.
Hello.
Until they fell in love with Greaves.
I was like the symbolism of putting something out.
That one was perfectly taken off, but it was from the anime.
I don't know.
Breathe, breathe, breathe.
Breathe, breathe.
I bet my fondle abysmal be yours.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll be here.
Don't you fall, he sounds really short.
Have faith in me.
I'll be here.
What?
Ah.
That's so sweet.
I'll be here.
The business formal attire.
Dig in up.
Dig.
What?
Okay.
Oh.
They've made a cock block joke.
Oh, they got jokes.
They got stand-up comedy.
Wait, what does it mean?
I'm too slow.
We're killing his wife?
I'm not ready.
I don't have enough tears in the tear duct just yet.
You're going to need to slow down on the sad plots
if that's what's going to happen.
Bye.
No.
If we destroy,
the island grace will perish too.
Because there's no replacement things.
Oh my god, it's a utopia for robots.
It's like a spider web of connection.
Sorry, I've still got to snore up my nose.
Excuse me for a moment.
I don't know if you understand.
Hydrogen check.
Hello, go home.
Hello.
He can fly, but they keep rolling.
Rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling.
What?
Kitty.
Like a safe house.
Oh my god, hello.
Hello.
I enjoyed it.
Descendant minions.
Hello.
Uh, y'all got any guns?
Oh, you understand?
Oh.
Can we save it?
Wouldn't it be better to assassinate Toke to prevent all this?
Oh, we fucked up? What was in that code? It's red! Everything's red!
Oh, we fucked up! We fucked up!
Are we done, Guft?
Well, you got your wish. You got your wish. Why don't you just kill Toke?
You got your wish.
Oh, fuck.
Him again? Give it a rest, buddy. We've had enough of you. Wrap it up.
You know, go get a fucking part-time job or something.
Oh, my God, we fucking just fucked up the city.
Whoa! I saw them titties. Hold on. Go back to frame. No, no, no. Don't roll the credit.
Go back to frame. I saw them titties.
Hold on. I see that again.
I see that again one more time. Before we go to the next episode, hold on a minute.
I knew what I saw. I knew what I saw.
Right, episode six. I knew what I saw.
I knew what I saw.
Okay, we're ready for episode six.
Team Rocket got a new rabbit. Team Rocket's blasting off again.
Are you ready?
As always, I will say three, two, one, go. I know I should probably not be spammed.
Like, I should be given as a break to analyze that episode.
But because I'm solo IQ, I can't analyze anything.
So I'm just ready to go next, you know? Next.
Booba to distract the two. Real.
Okay. On the count of go.
Three, two, one, go.
I still don't have a scene that I want to get out of.
Oh, we're going to learn by his piss.
Oh.
Oh, damn, this is short gone.
Oh, fuck.
That's him as a weed, right?
I have terrible news. I think she's telling the truth.
Oh, for fuck's sake, we're getting a bit technical, aren't we?
Oh, I'm watching.
New robot mum, real Andrew.
Gentoo robot confirmed.
Uh...
I don't like where this is going. Call me John Tron, because I don't like where this is going.
The scientists didn't even know this would happen.
Well, so we teddy bear looked into it and was like, oh, I couldn't have come up with this.
So I don't know why he's acting all surprised.
Or was he? Maybe he wasn't...
Maybe he was acting surprised at Vivi jumping in the water.
But not surprised at the result.
What if it goes there?
There's something to be said for a dispassionate arbiter in hard emotional time.
Mom, we need like a horny frame of something. Give us anything so I can get some artwork.
Teddy bear is performing his role as magical girl's evil talking pet.
He'd be up on the mirror like, hey, little mama, let me whisper in your ear.
Uh...
But it wasn't...
told Feverino's, because he doesn't want his waifu to shut in.
What part? Stay still, they won't understand.
Because I'm not the one causing you harm, little fucker.
What are you doing?
No...
vation...
but a lie, while you're waiting.
YAGACE
Is he going to get redemption arc?
Liar
Thank you for watching!
Ponder, ponder, ponder, ponder
Metronome is a Pokemon attack!
Oh, are we about to break history? Make history sorry?
Once there's a ship that she'll to see
Sooner or later, the mother might come
Imagine all the things in that world at hand
One day, will my name spread worldwide
Will my name spread worldwide
Groomed by the vehicle
We skipped a few, bruv, wrap up the song
Thank you for watching!
Awww
Oh, she died during childbirth?
Reconnected
Huh?
It clicked?
I know that was supposed to be Chair Shuffle MP3, it sounded like a 2
What's her song?
I've used up all my tears for one day
She revives D.Va?
During childbirth
Hmm
This time we dry, we drain, straw, knee, dry, real
How did they clap with no hands because he double cheeked up?
Do we babby?
Hmm
No one comes to the museum anymore?
Yeah
Danny, stay post-grader?
Teddy is Matsumoto
Huh
Wait, Teddy took the creator's name
Round Papaga
We're in the future, 100 years in the future
I don't remember the look of the person
Oh, piss
Well, we're not in episode 11 yet
I know I changed the number, but we're not in 11 yet
Yeah
Oh, shit
No spoilers, right, that's spoilers, I'm not looking at that, that's spoilers
Right, episode 11
Oh my god
They didn't change anything after that, I don't know
Are you ready to go next?
I'm just going to wrap it all up
Okay, are you ready?
On goal, 3, 2, 1, go
That's all we fucking steered off the path
You're splitting all different
Can she even help?
Help
Everyone's terrified of AI
Oh
They identified hers, but
No
I hope everyone's having a good time
Oh yeah, you could say that
Kinda
Group karaoke, look what happens
I don't know, singers on the make spoil the audio
I farted
But in the end, it didn't even matter
I'm very curious how this ends
I'm very curious
This is brutal
Thank you for watching
It was
That's him right here
Where is
We're there
We did something though
We'll send it
I'm a bit too slow for this scene
Oh
Do I not need to keep the timeline going and send it?
The birdies come in the goodies
Chaps about taking half a year's time
What could you do against that, honestly?
Oh
Elizabeth?
Yeah, that can be right
Oh
No
Yeah, it's Elizabeth
Uh
She has the clown tags of that guy that turned into a machine in her head
Oh
Yeah
Hmm
I'm like 90% sure we technically perished him
Yeah
I was there
Oh
Hmm
Okay, thank you
I'm facing my pastoral
Okay
He's pissing
Sorry
I don't know where this is gonna go
A little bit
Singin' with you
Hmm
One upgrade, thanks
That's the Moto Peeler class
We get to blow up, T-Fuck
Uh
We can't even make it to space
There's a sulka
What
Hmm
I didn't fucking end it there, what the fuck
Okay
Episode 12
Are you ready for episode 12
Ready
Okay
What
There's one more episode after this, okay
Okay
This anime has grown on me
Ready
Okay
Oh
Hmm
Okay
What the fuck did it say
Hmm
The silence important part to drop later, real
Okay
Hmm
Oh the dialogue, they're hating so much dialogue from us
Stop hating the dialogue
Hmm
I'm getting nervous
No
Oh
Okay
Hmm
Oh
Okay
It's him but evil
The fuck we got shagged
Okay
Hmm
We failed
Huh
You can feel anatomy
Okay
Does it look right on your end though for episode 13?
Does this look wrong?
Is this episode 13.5? Wait a minute, have I put the wrong one on?
I put the wrong one on! Hold on! Hold on! Pause! I put the wrong one on! I put the wrong one on! I put 13.5 on!
Maybe this is English. Copy them. Maybe this is English. Hold on! Hold on! I put the over on! I put the over on!
Cause it was 13.5 in the file, it comes before 13. Hold on a minute! Everyone bring it back! Bring it back!
Bring it back meddd! and go back to the start. Back to the start meee!
That's the rewind sound, okay? Sorry there's an over episode and it was in Japanese.
Okay. Ready? For episode 13, okay? 3..2..1..GO.
Please be English. Please be English. Please be English. I'm too small-brained
to read subtitles at the same time. Give me that English. I even know what an over is. I just said
over. Give me that English. Okay, there's that dreaded song.
I don't know what happens to him. Or something else is going to happen to him.
Okay, it's in English. We're winning. Emotional reattachment coming back in.
Hi. Pleasure.
Would mummies still love us even if we wrote in Japanese? I would just, it would be harder because I need to read.
You know that anime that is like, read, read. And I'm like, no. Title drop in the episode.
Didn't even know if I got an English dub. You know, you all know my secret. I've been
listening in English all the time. You've been listening in Japanese this whole time?
I feel like it's so much harder to read the subtitles and get so emotionally involved.
We figured it out. No. You never know my secret. I'm a fake weeb.
English. I figured since there are no subs in the blur image.
We must weeb a five or more. Plop, plop, plop. Get weeped, get weeped, get weeped. Really get
weeped. Fakling mummy, honestly. We'll have to return you to the store, real.
Most weebs got a job and can't watch anymore. And directly anymore.
Sorry, I saw him lift the gun out. I'll do the sound effects for you.
Pursuing or what?
You wanna go?
Okay.
Where are you making those lines in your head when we...
I just hit the biggest fucking floor ever.
You wanna sniff?
Okay, they're gonna do it.
Canee!
Pregento?
Absolutely.
Some day it's not gonna be a farm.
Folks say that. They're like, oh, if you never shit yourself, it'll happen eventually.
I mean, I'm doing pretty good so far. My record is zero, so... I don't know.
Canee!
Indulged in one... Canee?
I get to hear you this time.
Canee!
You plopped in the water.
Aww.
Little bubba. Thank you, Teddy. Let's do it in the same.
Canee! Too canee!
Indulged in two... Confirmed.
The too canee.
She's gonna sing the can song.
Right, this time we're wrapping tinfoil in it. We put the wrong can to think.
We put bacon paper over it instead of the other can.
I'm setting up for this again.
My legs are crisscross applesauce as the American say.
And they're in the right timeline!
Oh, that's a bit sad.
At least he gets to be with life and the kids.
Tinfoil time, tinfoil time.
Okay, let's see.
I have a little bit of bread, Brun.
What?
She fucking gave her her last lanes? Ooh.
Fucking read her last words? I'm not sure about that, Ian.
That was a really unique...
By the way, when you were dying, this is what you said to me.
What the fuck?
Oh dear, oh dear. Hydration check. Oh dear, oh dear.
Sorry, I've got dry throat.
Okay, hydration, hydration, hydration.
I'm going to hold the move, rather cocky.
I think she's really held up well.
Hmm?
Hmm.
Damn.
Can it touch us?
What?
Yeah, that's it.
Okay.
I have to comment.
Hmm.
Sorry, that was my tummy if you heard that.
But her deal?
Hmm.
Why does that have to kill her to sing though?
Did she really have to die?
A few tears.
I don't get it, I don't really get it.
That's it, that's it.
There's no happy ending.
Fucking write a happy ending, challenge impossible.
So what's an oval then?
I don't understand what an oval is.
Oh it's the man she saved.
Is that her eyes?
No.
What?
I don't understand.
That's it, that's the fucking end.
Bro, how am I supposed to win me when you're in chess when I look like this?
So that's the end of that storyline, there's no like season 2.
No notes from the director being like in another universe, she's still right there.
That's like grey.
That's it.
Well literally the AI pops up again?
I'm in shambles but that was a good time, I mean...
But we won't do that, we don't want to do that.
It's kind of nice to have this ending when it's in a while, speak for yourself.
I'm not sure what to think.
I don't know, I think you have to think for me unironically, I'm like...
Vivi will live on in her memories?
Can we not just all hold hands and get along?
Oh my god, don't be so dramatic.
Can we like hold hands and get along?
Oh my god.
That was awful.
I don't know about you but that was fucking awful.
Oh I'm getting flashbanged.
I love watching sad ending animes for some reason, showing us what happens in that.
Humans and AI found a way to live in harmony without the war.
I mean I hope that's what the ending implied.
She succeeded but the cost of her own life she fulfilled her mission.
Would you rather end on episode 12?
I don't know what happened on episode 12.
I don't know what to feel, fuck.
Now I'm going to be honest, I was supposed to be stream sniped in chess.
I'm going to be honest, I don't really feel like battling out over the fucking knight in the bishop right now.
I'm a bit distraught after that anime.
I'm not going to lie.
Everyone died with the style.
I mean shit, it's a better ending.
But fuck, can we have a good ending?
And Vivi, is that too much to ask for?
They fucking cut her hair and everything.
You couldn't have made her look older if you wanted to.
I mean shit, I'm like if I look at marshmallows are they going to cheer me up?
Or is it going to be like, here's my booby.
Okay.
Yeah, anime.
Ten out of ten on the anime.
I mean, I don't even know what to say.
I think I need to sleep on it, honestly.
I don't think I'm ready for chess either.
Okay, I'm glad we're in agreement with that.
Our boobies don't cheer her up, she hates us.
I don't like, oh the fuck.
I think I need a nap after that, honestly.
That was cheeky.
Can we just watch hentai next time?
I feel like that'd be a lot more easier for me.
Top-rated hentai at school.
You think I'm joking?
Best hentai anime, top ten one.
Number one.
Boku to joy and emotions.
I can read that.
Yeah, we're doing something nice next time.
I'm like emotionally distraught.
I don't know how you look right now,
but my eyes are bulging at my skull from the puffiness.
You should try keigo.
Why not do a keigo on your tentacle?
Made an absolute lie out of that stream title though.
Oh god, what did I name the stream?
Am I going to cry?
Bruh, I cried every single episode, I think.
That was awful.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Narrow, thank you.
Hope you liked it, mama-colon-nundaskor-love.
Sorry I made you cry.
It's a good anime though.
The music too, colon-nundaskor-love.
The music was beautiful.
I liked that the intro and the outro had different things.
Pardon me.
Thank you, Narrow, for the super chat.
Sorry I'm burping.
I need something silly in fan service.
Yes, please.
What made you cry the most?
I'm crying, thinking about it.
The two birds when the sisters went down in the ship.
Just a wee bit sad.
Just a little bit sad when they went up into space.
That part got me the most.
Because I didn't expect it.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it next time.
I'll do that next time.
Is there anyone we can redirect into?
It says rescheduled on Mercy's stream.
Is she not streamin'?
Yes, I'm redirecting you five hours early.
Is she not?
Wait, I've been done.
1pm on the 6th.
Oh, it's not the 6th.
Okay, no one else is streamin' today.
As there is offline, Amazon, private.
Alright, I'll just leave it at that.
The crazy part is when Vivi came out,
many people skipped it because they saw the musical tag
and thought it was going to be a musical machine thing.
Yeah.
You always did love animals.
I can't handle an animal scene.
I'm just like, oh, I can't handle it.
Daily lives of high school boys.
It's 12 episodes long that's hilarious.
Okay.
It's okay, mummy.
We can have big, snotty, tear-filled cuddle sessions
to tear you off.
But your shirt would be soaked with that amount of tears
and snow.
I have to go around right now.
Oh.
Hey, Strony.
Hi, refund.
Another reason why someone might watch subtitles anime
is because of release time.
Normally, watching subs means you can watch it sooner
than later.
Dubs are slower to come out.
I was watching Naruto, the English dub
with like 100 episodes behind.
Oh, go, go, go, go.
Hey, mom, may I refund?
Hotel Internet keeps cutting out.
You know, hotel?
Who are you pumping?
I can only really watch the watch live,
but I wanted to say I love you.
And as Paris socials, it sends you a big part of my life
and encourages me to be a better person.
That's lovely, refund.
I'm so sorry I'm crying through you.
Read in your message.
I'm like tearing up.
Oh, I love you too, little refund.
I'm glad you're late.
It encouraged me to be a better person,
but I was inside you all along.
You just needed the motivations
and I gave you a little kick up your arse.
And now you get to be the best version of yourself.
Yeah?
I was thinking about your anime watch along
so it came to me in a flash.
Interviews with Monster Girls is one season.
It's basically a big Monster Girl lore fest
in a fairly comfy slice of life Monster Girl framework.
It's on the light end of each word,
but it has enough fan service.
Okay, maybe we'll do something like that.
It's fine, we love exposure to Mummy's emotions.
I don't want to make you so upset
when I'm greeting through everything though.
Like, all I do is cry.
Mummy, I'd like to second the Kaiju recommendation.
Silly fan service anime
and sports of girl butt bouncing themselves
off of platforms over war.
I think it's a reference to something I don't know yet.
Interview with Monster Girls is cute and fun, yeah.
We're gonna give, I mean, as I said,
this is only the fifth of this month,
so the next anime watch along is like a whole month away.
There's gonna be a big...
I'm not even sure I want to get anything
from a fan art of me and any of the scenes in this anime
because it has wrecked me.
Okay, I'm so upset.
At least for the first one, it's like, yeah, black male.
Yeah, fuck yeah, that's hot.
You get to put
my foot on your brooch type thing
in Britain, yeah, like that, that's good.
But yeah, we're not upset.
We're head partying and vaping.
I just don't want to make you too upset.
Well, I'm upset. Hope you feel better.
I don't know what a bobby is, but...
and then the reflins spell out
a weiner
and a bobby
in emoticons. A bobby
is a weiner.
A bobby is your tentacle.
You'd go, oh, mommy, my bobby's hard.
Stroney holding bird up to flying at this guy.
Are you trying to kill me? Because that'll kill me.
What about an artwork are you wearing Vivi's idol?
I think I'd throw up if I see
any more Vivi stuff for the next few days.
Hi, Stroney. Hi, reflin.
I found out I have mostly Scottish
and Irish heritage. We make be cousins.
You want to fuck your cousin?
I'm from Alabama.
Oh my gosh, I'm dying.
I can't help but cry with you, mommy.
Don't worry, we can get snot all over my shirt.
I don't mind.
Let me lift up your shirt and get
snot all over your skin.
You want me to blow my nose on you?
Jeez.
I'm not going to redirect into anyone
because I'm too emotionally drained
and I don't want to chat in someone's chat
being like, yeah, just watch
emotionally draining anime in my life.
By the way, don't watch Vivi. You'll die.
Yeah.
Are you guys going to be okay if I go, though?
I don't want to leave
I don't want to leave Upset.
I don't want to leave you
because we're both upset, you know?
Wait, so don't get
a scrawny in the Vivi Idol outfit come?
I don't know.
I think save your money on that one, chief.
I'm going to be honest. Actually, keep that money
to yourself and buy yourself a little chocolate
quat long or something with it instead
or a pan of chocolate. Sorry.
Chocolate quat long shit, pan of chocolate. Good.
Keep that money for yourself.
Don't get anything
Vivi inspired, I think I'll die.
We'll be alright.
Dude, you're gone, but we'll be okay.
Niichijo
is basically comedy made by
random things happening. I think mommy would like that.
Oh, more tears on the face
moments, you see?
Can we put some anime
recommendations on Marshmallow? Of course you can!
You're more than welcome to.
We have a maximum emotional exchange, don't sweat it.
We won't want to
tap you while you're drinking.
Make sure to hydrate well.
When you turn it into a dried squid
you know how you can buy dried squid in Japan?
I'm in one of those packets right now, I'm not dehydrated.
Have you seen Konosuba
mummy? Cause that's a fun one.
I've not seen Konosuba.
Konosuba is peak, is it?
Wah. Okay.
I'm going to go lie down
and cry and think about my emotions
and process what I've just consumed.
Yeah, next time
don't be surprised
if we watch something a bit more upbeat
cause I can't be handling these tears every two things.
Every movie I watch
I cry, every anime I watch I cry.
Well, cry the laughter on the first one.
That doesn't count, but yeah.
Don't forget to replenish
your salt, honestly.
How about
Strongie and the schoolgirl outfit?
And the archive?
I mean, I'm not going to tell you what to do with your money.
I see the schoolgirl outfit is better
I feel like I'm too emotionally distraught
to look at anything that resembles a movie for the next few days.
It's called 100 Girlfriends
that really, really love you. It's hilarious, wholesome, etchy
rom-com parody
with great visual humour.
Here's a little tip
for condolences.
Please rest well.
Thank you, MP bucket.
The Tropic Thunder.
I swear if I cry
that's supposed to be a comedy.
I've never seen
Tropic Thunder.
We love that you're a sensitive little bean.
Hold on a minute.
Don't talk about my sensitive bean like that.
I'm trying to give her happy tears.
Honestly.
There's plenty of laughs
in Tropic.
What's the agendination tomorrow?
The agendination tomorrow
is
a collab or castle crashers.
I've never played that before
so I'm going to have to play it offline.
I'll make a deal. I'll go for a nap
and then I'll play castle crashers to see what it's about
and then I'll do the collab
and then we'll do the member drawing history.
I'm still distraught though
just so you know I'm still distraught.
Everyone deploy the upbeat anime suggestions
honestly.
I'm like
I didn't expect to greet so hard
for the reeflings
that are into me crying. You're eating good in this one.
Your must be
full master in this entire expedition
that we went through.
Remember I hired her, yes.
I think
I deserve a good little nap
after this one.
I didn't expect this was a cute anime
that's got song mentions, a little bit of music
and then it's
you're cute when you cry
honestly.
Right.
My arse
is going to go.
I'm not going to redirect into anyone
because we're too emotionally distraught right now.
Are you going to be okay?
Is the real question
the part of the question
is what I'm wondering.
Crying equals
inking? I think some reeflings
like on a cry in a
factual way.
It gets them going.
Considering we don't have a policy yet,
I volunteer my body for a post crying
streaming session.
You put creaming sessions
to.
Big stretch.
Okay. How many episodes
of that? You're going to get 13 of the most
depressed and kisses I can offer.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
I'm going to have a nap.
I'll feel better after the nap.
Okay.
Five, six, seven, eight.
Three.
I sort of
pray.
Oh no, it's 13.
Was that five more?
One.
Nine.
10.
11.
12.
13.
Right.
I'll see you tomorrow.
I'll be bright-eyed and bushy-tailed.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I was so short
for the post-yap
of the stream contents.
But as you can tell, I'm just a wee bit
distraught right now.
So we're going to be watching Hentai next
time.
We're all just going to be jerking off main.
I'll see you tomorrow.
I love you.
I'm sorry about wiping my snarl over your shirt.
Okay.
Bushy-tailed.
Right. I'll see you tomorrow.
Please enjoy yourselves. I'm so sorry.
Bye-bye.
Make sure to hydrate too.
See you tomorrow.
Kiki.